avec augusta lunardi journaliste
indépendante augusta lunardi merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors depuis le début de l'épidémie du
coronavirus jaillir ball scénario semble
ignorer les mesures simples de
prévention contre le nouveau coronavirus
c'est bien cela racontez nous font
exactement ça a commencé le 7 mars
usain bolt sonar ont effectué un voyage
officiel aux états unis où vingt trois
membres de son équipe ont été infectées
par le comité 19 donc pour le sonar où
il devrait rester en isolement pendant
14 jours mais il n'a pas du tout
respecté les consignes de ce médecin
quelques jours plus tard il est allé
serrer la main armée même prendre des
selphy avec des partisans réunis dans
une manifestation pro gouvernement à
brasilia et pour lui le coronavirus
n'est qu'une petite grippe
une hystérie créé par les médias il dit
que l'épée demi ferait plus de mal au
porte-monnaie qu'à la santé du pays
et c'est pour ça qu'il a encouragé les
brésiliens de continuer de travailler
le gouvernement a d'ailleurs créé une
coop baptisé le brésil ne peut pas
s'arrêter mais la justice brésilienne a
récemment interdit la diffusion de la
vidéo en accusant mme olson arrow de
faire de la désinformation sur les
réseaux sociaux et même à des
plateformes comme facebook twitter ou
instagram ont décidé de supprimer la
vidéo associé à tous les comptes de
jaillir molson euros alors on a
également entendu le ministre de la
santé brésilien lui prôné davantage la
distance distanciation sociale
finalement à l'encontre de ce que dit
jacques bolson araud quelle est
l'atmosphère au sein de ce gouvernement
alors malgré les déclarations de vaud le
sauna rôle après par les brésiliens a
suivi les consignes des maires et des
principales villes et des gouverneurs et
ont déjà commencé un isolement
volontaire il ya deux semaines alors que
le pays comptait moins de 100 cas
confirmés du nouveau coronavirus mais
les gouverneurs et les maires ils ont
d'ailleurs très rapidement contrairement
à molson arrow comme l'affirmé sur des
écoles ou alors affirmé tueur de tous
les commerces non l'essentiel
donc oui les brésiliens semblent
effrayés est beaucoup plus inquiet que
les européens en face à cette épidémie
et au sein de la classe politique sur le
dossier du commis de 19
est ce que j'ai l'air ball sonar ou
encore des soutiens alors granero il a
en effet de moins en moins de soutien il
ya une sorte de guerre froide installé
entre le président de la république et
le ministre des sports et de la santé le
ministre est soutenu par la majorité du
gouvernement comme le vice président le
ministre de la justice le ministre de
l'économie
les gouverneurs les maires et même les
leaders du parlement donc le seul
soutien politique sur lequel bolton
avant peut encore compter ce sont ses
trois fils qui ont été élus députés et
sénateurs en 2019 19 lui 18 pardon et ce
sont les derniers à se tenir les
positions de paulson arrow face à cette
épidémie
alors là a pris également aujourd'hui
l'état va verser une aide de 100 euros
par mois des dizaines de millions de
travailleurs du secteur informel pour
les aider à traverser la crise un projet
de loi a été approuvé en urgence par le
congrès alors que le brésil enregistrait
165 morts et plus de 4600 cas confirmés
mardi prévue par la constitution mais
jamais appliquée l'impôt sur la fortune
fait également surface
comment est ce que la population perçoit
ces annonces dans le pays alors la
population est très inquiète il faut
savoir que 40 % des brésiliens sont des
travailleurs informels les travailleurs
autonomes
cette mesure même si elle a déjà été
approuvée elle n'est pas encore validé
donc ces personnes n'ont pas encore vu
cet argent sur leur compte bancaire et
la situation est très très très inquiet
sur très inquiétante pardon surtout dans
les quartiers les plus défavorisés parce
que plus de 13 millions de brésiliens
habitent dans des quartiers très
compliqué comme les favelas dans des
maisons imbriquer les unes sur les
autres
souvent elles n'ont aucun services
sanitaires de base par exemple dans la
favela où je me suis rendu à san paolo
pour faire son reportage les habitants
de cette favela avait souffert une
pénurie d'eau de plus de six heures
c'est dans quelques jours avant donc la
peine où l'épidémie aurait déjà commencé
au brésil donc il est impossible pour
ces gens de suivre les consignes
sanitaires de le ms est le plus
inquiétant c'est que beaucoup d'entre
eux ont perdu leur travail durant la
main et se sont retrouvés sans aucun
revenu à temps dans sa cabine
du coup quelles sont les grandes
inquiétudes vis-à-vis de ces populations
pour ces populations des favelas ce
notamment quels sont les inquiétudes des
associations des ong ou même des partis
politiques au brésil
bah c'est surtout la nourriture
ces personnes ne savent pas comment ils
vont faire pour manger ce sont des
travailleurs comme j'ai dit avant
informel donc ils gagnent sans réalisme
c'est l'équivalent à 2 à 20 euros par
jour
donc ils ne savent plus comment on va
faire pour acheter tout simplement de la
nourriture
il ne s'inquiète pas tant que ça du
corps d'un virus il veut juste continuer
de travailler continuer d'acheter de la
nourriture parce qu'ils s'inquiètent ils
ne s'inquiètent pas d'acheter un du gel
hydro alcoolique ou alors des
médicaments il venait juste continuer
d'acheter le par angers pour ses enfants
et pour leur famille alors il ya une
autre population qui s'inquiète sont les
leaders indigènes de toute l'amérique du
sud
ils ont aussi mis en garde cette semaine
contre la menace existentielle que pose
le coït 19 pour leur communauté
il lance un appel désespéré pour une
protection contre la pandémie
c'est un vrai danger également pour ces
communautés oui exactement leur
situation est très délicate
surtout pour le peuple qui sont encore
très isolé c'est à dire qu'ils ne sont
pas en contact avec le reste du pays
mais les groupes d'autochtones du brésil
de la colombie et l'équateur une aussi
du pérou ont pris des mesures très
rapidement ils ont interdit l'entrée de
tous les visiteurs extérieurs sur le
directoire jean et ce sont des mesures
essentielles très importante car ces
communautés sont extrêmement vulnérables
ils y ont beaucoup souffert à cause
d'eux des épidémies par exemple il faut
savoir que les maladies a mené par les
colonisateurs européens indécis mais 90%
de peuples autochtones d'amérique donc
qu'ils y sont extrêmement inquiet
d'autant plus qu'ils sont très isolés
ils n'ont pas accès aux médecins au
centre de santé comme le reste de braise
ignore ou alors deux américains du sud
pour terminer est ce que l'opposition
politique a mis en place des initiatives
justement pour contrer le comportement
du président jaillir bolton a roué et
qu'est-ce qui le risque est ce que ça
pourrait aller jusqu'à la destitution
alors il est difficile à savoir c'est
vrai que la légèreté avec laquelle
volent sonar au vert la crise du courant
à merris énerve beaucoup l'opinion
publique et surtout la classe politique
brésilienne
les députés de l'opposition et les
maires de l'opposition récemment déposé
une demande officielle de destitution du
président brésilien en l'accusant de
clean de responsabilité pour avoir
ignoré les consignes de ms et pour avoir
participé aux manifestations alors que
l'épidémie avait déjà commencé dans le
pays
mais c'est trop tôt pour savoir ce qui
va se passer dans les prochains jours ou
même dans les prochains mois ça va
dépendre du scénario politique brésilien
qui comme d'habitude est très instable
merci beaucoup augusta lunardi d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste indépendante au
brésil